What if I told you that we built this
fully SEO and geo optimized website with
relevant service pages, images, internal
linking, fully built-in schema with
location pages, all in a couple of
minutes using this new AI tool? Well, we
did and that tool is called Rank Site.
So, Rank Site allows you to enter in
details of your local service business
for now. We're going to have a general
website or block theme coming soon. So,
we want to enter in
business information like your business
name, phone number, which cities or
which provinces or which areas you
target, your tagline, what you do, a
little bit more about your business,
such as your services, where you're
located, and some of the work that
you've done.
And once you've entered in that
information, you can also upload your
logo and then customize your brand
color. Once you do so, you can add a
form. So, if you add a free API form
from FormSpree or Web 3 Forms, as you
can see, your form is going to be
working in your homepage. So, not only
it's going to be a beautiful SEO
website, you're also going to be able to
optimize for leads and optimizing for
actually getting conversions on your
website. So, you can enter in your
FormSpree
or your sorry, your FormSpree API and
then you simply go ahead and click
generate with AI and you'll be able to
build a beautiful website like this.
Once you generate the website, then
you'll be able to see the site
structure. So, we've already went ahead
and generated some of this content here,
but it's super easy. Once you have the
um the site structure or the pages, you
can always add or remove any pages. You
simply go ahead and click create with
AI. You'll need to add in your Open
Router API key because it's a BYOK,
which actually is better in the long run
for your cost savings. So, we simply go
ahead and click generate and within a
couple of minutes, that page will be
generated. So, if you take a look at one
of the generated pages already, we can
see that we get a a SEO title, a SEO
meta description, we get full HTML
content, so everything is HTML
indexable. We see the highlight cards,
right? So, we can actually edit this. We
can edit our FAQ.
We can also go ahead and add an image.
So, we can add any images that we like
onto that page, and then we go ahead and
we can click publish. We also, if we
scroll down here, we also have our
schema. So, we have our service type
schema already baked into every single
one of these pages. So, all of your
pages are going to be SEO optimized with
the relevant schema. Now, another
really, really powerful feature is we
have the ability to index this page. So,
you know, if you're a new site, it often
takes time for Google to be able to
index your website. We found a way in
which you can manually index to Google
without actually going into Google
Search Console and doing it yourself.
So, you can actually go ahead and click
index this page,
and you can see that it's submitted to
Bing, Yandex, and AI Search, and it's
also submitted to Google indexing. If
you go over to settings and search
engine indexing, we can see here that um
our page has been indexed, and we can go
ahead and check the status and see how
that page is doing. Very, very powerful
feature. We also can see our SEO energy
score. If you run this audit, we can see
where we're missing and where we can
improve. But, every single website out
of the box comes out with a robots.txt,
llms.txt,
AI JSON, sitemap.lll, llm, and so on.
So, you just need to go ahead and enter
in your entity signals, which is your
business name and things of that nature.
But, overall, everything is solid and
you can also see your SEO checklist for
every single page. You can go ahead and
make any changes as needed. So, if we go
ahead and take a look at any of these
websites a little bit more, we can see
that it is a beautiful-looking website
and it's customizable for any single
niche. Let's go over to PageSpeed
Insights and we're going to do a live
testing of this website. While that test
is running, let's go ahead and take a
look at some of the other features. We
also have the ability to add blog posts.
Now, these blog posts will generate
beautiful articles because we're
actually using Word Rocket under the
engine. So, the articles that you get
back is high-quality, in-depth articles
with custom images. You can choose as
many images as you like. You also get
your title, you meta description, and
you'll also get your blog post schema in
every single article. There is no
website builder that has these SEO
features baked in with automation and AI
to allow you to build and grow sites
easier.
We also have a keyword section coming
soon. This is where you'll be able to
research keywords, to see keywords that
you can write on, or keywords um about
topics, or blog posts, or articles that
you should target for your website. So,
you can look at this as an all-in-one
SEO optimized website building platform.
So, this website, as we can see here,
scores 93 for performance, 96 for
accessibility, 100 for best practices
and SEO, and we have three out of three
for agentic browsing, which is really,
really good. For mobile, we're going to
improve our performance here at 72, but
again, 100 for best practices and SEO,
and 96 accessibility. But, most
importantly, it's three out of three for
agentic browsing. So, that means that
this website is ready to be picked up by
AI search, rank in AI search, and help
you get more ChatGPT, Perplexity, uh and
other AI search mentions. So, if you
guys want to get access to this tool, it
is launching this week. There'll be a
link below today's video. Depends on
when you're watching this video, either
there will be a wait list or you'll be
able to use this tool for yourself. In
the beta launch, you're going to have a
much, much more free
usage. So, you'll be able to use it a
lot more, build out your sites, and
there'll also be a beta launch pricing
that you can take advantage of. If you
guys have any questions, let me know in
the comments below. And as always, I
hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video. And again, if you want to get
access to this tool, there will be a
link below today's video. Take care.